[Music]
okay thank you thank you so much for
taking your time for my vision
what is ml ops the best practices for
DevOps for ml I'm Kaz I'm a developer
advocate so it's like a evangelist for
developers and engineers I'm focusing on
data analytics products like a tensor
for machine learning engine and bigquery
I have been working at Google for us
seven years and what is ml ops actually
I and my colleague has created this
world there was no mm ops world every
BOTS such a that stands for the devil's
4ml and I have been collecting this
concept or topics of the operating
production machine running systems for a
couple of years because I haven't keep
hearing from the emitter expert that
watching is easy but the operating is
hard from customers and internal DMA
experts when there was there's a 1 ml
expert in Google who has been supporting
the one of the Rogers ml service inside
Google for many years and he said
launching the first version of immune
system is easy but operating it for many
years is the hardest part so I thought
maybe the practices for DevOps could
work well for building the production
quality email systems I copied the
distillation of the a box from Wikipedia
it says it's all about unifying the
depth part and Oxford and strongly
advocated automation and monitoring for
all steps for the systems so you can
replace that but IT portal system part
with ml so to build the production
quality ml systems is important to
unifying the ml development and
operations and advocate automation and
monitoring of the email systems and we
have been publishing a cup of the year
the papers in pass such as the ml
machine learning the highest interest
credit card of technical debt I call it
as an MAO technical debt paper that was
written
by an American side Google who has been
operating the large-scale machine
running projection system for many years
and they haven't learned many things in
past over 10 or 15 years and they have
written the best practice as a papers
another important paper is gurus or
machine learning or rule swap email
paper and resolve papers and added with
the other many episodes I have collected
with the customers and customer
engineers I'm correcting many anti
patterns and solutions for the
production machine Manning systems and I
have three agendas for today
one is the anti patterns for development
time patterns for the deployment and
operation anti patterns so let's started
with the development ad patterns the
first pattern is the ml superhero maybe
you have seen see him in your company he
is a superhero because he is a
researcher who understand everything
like a mathematical model what's
happening inside his model but he also
has a skill set to build his own about
spark cluster by himself to do
everything from a pre privation data
prepped preparation or the
transformation training and also he has
a skill set and built and operating the
infrastructure by using kubernetes
writing the doc of I by himself
and also he can be a product manager who
can write the design dog by himself and
also he is a very prudent in
communicating with stakeholders Riker
she excels and executives and he does it
from the proof of concept phase to the
production phase he's a Superman but he
doesn't scale so the first project would
be awesome for by you know depending on
that kind of hero
but if Enterprise or startups want to
replicate the same reproduce the same
success with immense systems with many
different the features or odd products
or the divisions then you have to hire
that kind of super hero tens of them
so instead you have to build a team
scalable team by splitting the roles
into a much simpler roles so you could
have the multiple roles such as the MMO
researcher or data engineer
infrastructure engineer product manager
and business decision maker now let me
show one example of a team okay
all right so click on that and speak
into the mic may I have some gum so it
understood what you said may I have some
gum now it's going through natural
language processing it's identifying the
noun down there and gum so now it's
trying to it will then match based upon
the model that's been modified come on
come on come on and it is picking chewy
gum up and there the camera identified
extra long lasting watermelon gum now
the cameras the in app so I'm I gotta
keep this right yeah actually I've got
like seven boxes so that was the
demonstration we have built for the
ideal I you and next last year so some
of you may have seen this last year and
this was a demonstration but for us it's
a production machine running systems and
I designed it I have written a LOF
designer for this by myself and worked
with the vendor called brain pet in
Japan and who has expertise on building
the production machine running system
for many years
so we because I wanted to make a
production quality demonstration so I
asked them to build a team for this
because the i/o is not only the one
venue for these demonstrations we had to
present this demonstration at many large
events record next San Francisco next
Tokyo and India and many other places so
we cannot rely on the ml superhero so
the brain pad had created a team with
researcher who built the water to back
model running on tensorflow for the the
candy recommendation and also the image
commission and transfer are running and
also software engineer who uses the ml
api's of vision API is not vision API
speech-to-text api and an api hardware
engineer who focuses on how to control
the robot precisely and project manager
who leads the team and I was the the
business business decision maker
communicating Misty all the other
stakeholders Rekha marketing PR team and
legal everything so that one went well
because the the brain pad has a practice
to create a very tightly closed tightly
coupled it teams with the researchers
and engineers as a one team but
sometimes the youths have this problem a
black box that nobody understand if you
create a machine-learning team with the
researchers and engineers and equal
engineers is possible the nobody
understand the whole system because
researches would create the first
prototype with he or her his or her
jupiter notebook and then engineer takes
that code does the refactoring on that
to bring it to the production and then
we said the searches wouldn't do not
follow what's happening in the
production code at the same times maybe
engineer don't much knowledge about
what's happening inside the model itself
then nobody understand the what's
happening inside the whole system and
it's really hard for the optimization as
a whole system so the Amero technical
dead paper says at google
a hybrid research approach where
engineers and researchers are embedded
together on the same team that has
helped to reduce this source of friction
significantly so not only building
scalable team but also it's very
important to have a tight
cross communication between the air
researching and engineer to understand
everything and share their all the same
resources like a called a model and
model and for example maybe engineer can
help introducing a scalable platform
like a crowd america engine working with
a researchers
and because you can do that because here
we have introduced a new feature psychic
learn and exceed boost support on the
cloud mm engine not only getting serve
wall so for example researchers can
start using the socket land on Jupiter
notebooks to define their model and then
engineer work together to port it to the
crowd mm engine so let me show some
video that is created by Steve Greenberg
Steve Greenberg my colleague how you can
use the socket learn or machine learning
engine so for the first part
maybe the researchers can get started
with the Jupiter notebook to define the
usual socket learn model so you can use
the bigquery as for getting the training
data from database and you can use the
ordinary API own sake plan to do the
pre-processing or splitting data
everything yeah here's it is splitting
the data to the training data and test
data and you can also the pipeline API
of socket learn to to to build a
pipeline for training and then called a
fit function to train the model and try
the prediction and get the result so
this is the part researchers can do with
the usual practice and this is to where
you can get help from the ml engineer or
your infra engineer this is where you
are copying the saketram model to the
Google cloud straight so that the Amero
engine can radiate and also you can use
the ml ranging command to define and
version with that socket blur model
running on the ml engine like this and
finally you can try learning it with the
Amero engine so it is trying to try the
prediction with the circular model
running on the cloud and you can get
here same accuracy an important point
here is that by using the ml ranging as
the predictions serving infrastructure
for your circular model you don't have
to think about the much about your
scalability and availability by yourself
usually there's a huge gap between the
POC model PLC systems and the production
systems you have to think about how to
build your cluster with the kubernetes
and continuous and you have to think
about the right cycle up to each
instance and continents but by using an
ml engine it's much easier and engineers
can help that working with the
researchers to bring the POC code into
production so next slide next pattern is
chce or change anything changes
everything it's a very unique
characteristic or the behavior of MN of
systems
it's an entanglement you can find in the
ml systems that means a single change
one change to one feature could affect
all of the other features or single
changes in the hyper parameters or any
way you prepare your training data or a
feature that could change the behavior
of everything right here how you can do
your regularization regularization or
running late or sampling or threshold
that could change the behavior of the
whole system that's the reason why the
ml expert set launching easy but
ranching is easy but operating is hard
email rules of email purposes defines
rules or teams starting with an
interpretable model makes debugging
easier and this is another will rule
rapportive keep ensemble simples what is
the simple model so it's the deep model
the planning model is so attractive and
you can say to the business people that
we are using deep running it's an AI
system but sometimes the deep model
makes these complex so if you want to
use the model in your production systems
you can use that judiciously because
binya motor is much much much much
easier for debugging it's much easier to
turn the model and get the global
optimum whereas if you're using deep
model usually the model is in non-convex
that means you are not sure if you are
getting the best result from training or
not you have to make many trials
and also it is important to make the
everything interpretable by humans not
having a black box the another pattern
here or solution here is to use ensemble
models rather than using a huge one
monolithic model so you have a one big
deep model that takes hundreds of the
features from the dia system then it's
really hard to debug or troubleshooting
against that
so when practice you can use is to have
a smaller model small and simpler model
works just like a part factory for
automobile factory and you could have
another model that ensembles all the
idea synthesize the features from adidas
Park factories so it works as a assembly
plant and it's also important to have
everything's semantically interpreted
ball model so that the trouble the
persons for the troubleshooting wrecker
operatives can easily find what would be
the problem what would be the cause of
the problem is this this model this
model or this model rather than having a
gigantic one monolithic model where the
trouble would be embedded in somewhere
in the model so this I wanted to show
the servant one demonstration called
it's company it's a image crossfire for
the users built by the alternate
alternate is the largest provider for
the real-time auction for use occurs in
Japan and they handles over 5 million
auctions per year and they have built on
tens of all based image classifier or
specialized specialized for the users so
the users can upload the all the
different pictures of a car from
different angles rather from front back
or side or tires or steering wheels and
then system is cross-wired
that and you can get your car make and
model name and classification of these
images at high accuracy they have built
it and it has been on production for
over two years the one thing they did
when they are building the production
system well
to splitty model so oak net initially
created one big model d planning models
that takes all the features into it but
it ended up with splitting the model
into the smaller model so that they
found they were able to do better
troubleshooting or the better
optimization with the whole system ah
sorry about the why is that hmm
I'm sorry okay let me try it so it's
much easier for the production systems
and troubleshooting so that was here the
pattern you can see in the development
phase and let's take a look at the
deployment anti-patterns the first
pattern is lack of ml lifecycle
management the one scenario could be
maybe researcher with the start writing
the appeals if it's not Berg and he/she
just everything on it from POC to
production like a data preparation
transformation training validation and
serving and deploy and research you got
a high accuracy on the production
service but he would she would forget
about the system after one or two years
so after one year or two years maybe
somebody found the accuracy dropping
slowly and director of the business as
the researcher to update the model ASAP
like a by tomorrow
give the researcher is somehow somehow
find the all new topic on laptop
tries to remember how to go through
freaking the all the cells and do
everything able process manually anyone
that's why I mean doing the images
reprogramming he or she is a researcher
this is not his job so solution is to
think about the America cycle management
so integrated job management job
orchestration so that you can define it
all the comport component as a part of
the whole job orchestration starting
from the data ingestion analysis and
validation training and stabbing and
logging and monitoring not as the ad hoc
script running on the jipner notebook
you have to build everything as a
continuously deployment and repeatable
infrastructure depending not depending
on the researcher or me the one example
or building that kind of workflow is
using our goal our goal is an
open-source tool for the workflow as a
workflow engine for kubernetes contain
so you can use this tool to build that
this kind of video orchestration for
email system and actually we have tried
that for the one demonstration called AI
emotion this is a demonstration you can
find in the showcase area in the Moscow
nui south where we have the robot balls
rolling on the table and we have a
smartphone pixel to appabob
that takes you all the images of the
robot balls and running the object
detection model of the tensor alright
and control the robots by using sdk and
this object object detection model with
trainer are declared by using ml engine
and it also uses the video reinforcement
learning the RL to control the balls so
you if you're interested you can play by
yourself - by going to the D showcase
and we had to build the ml pipeline or
ml of workflow because the as you can
see it's very important to have the high
accuracy on the object detection at
every different venue
so each venue would have a different
lighting environment like the white
writing or the color lighting or
strength of the writings would be
different so it's important she'll be
able to retrain the model and get the
best result at each venue so as long as
the you were using the jipner notebook
and run using the manual process is not
scalable and portable as a demonstration
so for this demonstration we have built
the ml pipeline be by using our goal so
starting from the loading the training
data and training and evaluation and
also in this case we have built a
pipeline for converting everything into
a tensile flow right model converting
the tinsel flow right model and the
project in select files to the mobile
devices and let me show some example
this is still like the working algo user
interface for the AI emotion
demonstrations and the UI works just
right DUI you have any crowd
so if you'd click one of the workflow
you can see the first the current status
of the workflow like year you what's the
status is it succeeded or is it failed
or starting time and time and duration
just like the things you can see on the
qualitative law so by having this kind
of Education orchestration tool then you
don't have to go through the audit if
you know to not to be processed by
yourself manually instead you can have
someone like our operators or engineers
or the researchers pressing the buttons
of the workload the Argo to go through
all the repeatable process and deploy
between the module and deployed another
pattern you can see in the deployment
time is a lack of data validation in the
usual ordinary IT system the behavior of
the system is defined by the program how
do you have written so you have to write
a unit test to evaluate the behavior of
your system but what about the machine
learning system because you are not
lighting the code for defining your
behavior your system instead your system
would be using data training data to
define the behavior of system and how do
you bar get that the solution could be
the data validation tools and one option
is the tf-x or chance of fraud extended
that is an open source to provided by
the tensorflow team that provides the
multiple different useful tools for the
emeral ops practices such as the
transformation for the data or the model
analysis that are we talking about later
or the sobbing and one of these those
features is data validation at this
point we have it open source the data
validation part yet but we hope to have
it soon in the near future the by using
key effects for data validation you can
easily define the configuration file for
the digital validation
such as the type and domain for each
features or input data
whether it's a string or integer or what
kind of range it has or presence of the
instances of DG values or valency or
distribution by comparing the divergence
between two values and if it fits into a
certain threshold then it's okay
otherwise you have to check whether your
training data is okay on that and tf-x
paper says we want to use one we want
the user to treat data errors with the
same rigor and care that there is the
bugs in code because the data is your
code in your email system the actually
the Google Play team has introduced the
practice of data validation so that they
were able to increase the install rate
for applications for 2% so lastly I'd
like to discuss about the anti patterns
you can find in the operation time a
story about the mmm
why is that is it working
okay
now updating
maybe yeah we try connectivity
is it working well looks like it's not
my laptop fact is they switched yeah I
can continue with the other laptop yeah
and can I used here quicker oh yeah I
have it not working so robot walking
sorry about that
so lack of continuous monitoring so the
model any kind of model would see the
drop of the accuracy all the times
maybe it's going to be um it would take
our ears or maybe Cuates or months or or
hours but the accuracy would drop and if
there's no practice for use for your
team for continuous monitoring on your
accuracy or behavior or your model the
first person who'd notice the drop of
the accuracy will be the end user or
consumers so they will be frustrated
with the performance or experience and
business team would notice that and
director asked you to update their model
ASAP again so that's what you have to
want to avoid this is another pattern
training serving skill that means the
any single difference is reka
differences of the training data or
pre-processing the method method or the
windows you specify between training and
serving or ESET production that changes
the accuracy another button is not
knowing the freshness freshness
requirements so each email system would
have each own the freshness requirement
for example if you want to build the
news aggregation website then you may
want to update the mmm model every 5
minutes to get the latest updates
ecommerce site item recommendation may
count wait can't wait for couple days or
week and to updating the models the
natural rank is processing for customer
satisfaction
it may use the same model for a couple
months or maybe longer than that voice
recognition made doesn't require any
updates on the model object detection
sometimes requires the retraining the
module for every setup as I mentioned in
the a ie motion case and rules over a
mere paper says will be numbers 9 detect
problems before exporting models the
duty number eight know the freshness
requirements for your system and the
solution could be a Q&A or tensorflow
model analysis that is a new feature
included in the tensor flow to do
analytics on your model and by using GMA
you can follow some practices or new
rules such as the rule twenty-fourth
measure the Delta between the models
rather than watching the single accuracy
of the current model you have to see the
changes or trend of the between the
different models in time series how the
accuracy would be trending is it
increasing or is it decreasing another
practice you can use with this busy RMA
is using this right matrix for better
model analysis not only using a single
ROC or AUC number you can use the
different types of the features or
different the windows of the features to
get the deal to get the deeper insight
over the year behavior of your model
let me show some example of using each
year where May
this is stiff where the you importing
the tea women library and defines this
rises by using the APA over here hue by
using the Egyptian notebook and by
defining the slices in this case the
gist the code is using a Chicago taxi
trip data for training a model for
predicting the taxi fares in each trip
and the easiest wait is to get the a
single the ROC curve or the accuracy on
the whole model but by defining and
different slices like a thrust by the
the our in the day or day in a week or
year taking and you can understand much
more details about the behavior of your
model now it defines the slices so that
you can get the multiple accuracies for
each slices in this case is a time
series so you can see different
activities for provided for each slices
hour in a day and this the highest
accuracy is achieved at the noon time
where it is you would have many many
many attacks actually uses and once you
have confirmed that your model it works
as intended and there's no problem on
the accuracy or behavior then you can
use the diversion of the models on
machine learning engine the machine
running engine provides some the aps and
sheer i to register multiple versions of
your model and choose which one of the
models you want to use as a default so
you can use Sierra's command lines or
the ApS to define models and use it as a
default model
in other words the rules of the m/l
paper says the second rules is the first
design and implement metrics so if you
want to have any capture any problems or
want to capture any good things or good
feedback from customers define a matrix
to captains or observes behavior from
your emitter model for example Google
Plus team has been collecting many
metrics from the behavior user
activities such as how many expense per
read or how many wishes per week or how
many presents or comments per week so or
absolves these small matrix can show can
be a good input feature for defining the
goodness or post so that was the final
the practice in patterns so summary the
development anti-patterns you cannot
rely on a single ml superhero rather
than that you have to build a scalable
team and at the same time you cannot
make the you cannot build the ml black
box and you have to be aware that email
systems can have the chge or change
anything change everything the behavior
for deployment it's really important
think about the machine running like
cycle management by using the tools such
as could such as the Argo or the crud
composer and also you have to understand
the behavior of the email system is
defined by training data and your model
lastly it is very important to keep
monitoring and logging your systems so
it's very important to set up the
monitoring tool set and define the
refreshment requirement for your odd
machine running use cases by using the
tools Rocketeer ma and if you're
interested in those practices
please take picture of these links names
so you can learn more about these those
practices with those papers the ml
technical debt papers roots of ml papers
GFX and TF my main papers and I'd like
to give special thanks to Amy under
whose
the colleague or my dat
who's built this pyramid mo norihiro
Shimoda collected all the customer
episodes and case capability Arwa Amira
PI prime for the demonstration
so is that thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]